[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
قرا رجل عند يحيى بن معاذ فلما وصل الى
قوله تعالى
فقولا له قولا لينا لعله ويتذكر او يخشى
بكى يحيى وقال الهي هذا رفقك بمن قال انا
اله فكيف رفقك بمن يقول انت اله السلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]
الرقيب اسم من اسماء الله الحسنى ومعناه
الحافظ الذي لا يغيب عنه شيء ولا تخفى
عليه خافيه والذي لا يغفل عما خلق يقول
تعالى يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي
خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث
منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء واتقوا الله الذي
تساءلون به والارحام ان الله كان عليكم
رقيبا
اما الرقيب من البشر فارتبط بامور اخرى قد
لا تعجبك كثيرين
الرقيب هو الحارس والرقيب من الجيش
وطليعته والرقيد من يراقب الصحف والكتب
ليحذف منها ما يراه وما لا يراه وهناك
رقيب على نفسه يراقبها ينتقد اعماله فلا
يدع للناس سبيلا الى انتقاده
والرقيب الاشهر الذي كتب عنه العرب هو من
يراقب المحبين عادلا او ساعيا بالوشايه
يصف ابن حزم الاندلسي الرقيب بانه من افات
الحب وانه حمى باطنا وما اكثر قصص الغرام
التي افسدها الرقباء والوشات تقول ولاد
بنت المستكفي
اصونك من لحظات الظنون واعليك عن خطرات
الفكر واحذر من لحظات الرقيب وقد يستدام
الهوى بالحذر
[موسيقى]
خرج بعض ملوك الفرس الى الصيد فكان اول ما
استقبله اعور فتطير به وامر بضربه وحبسه
ثم خرج وتصيد صيدا كبيرا فلما عاد راجع
نفسه في طيارته فاستدعى الاعور وامر له
بصله فقال الاعور لا حاجه لي في صلتك ولكن
ائذن لي في الكلام فقال الملك تكلم قال
لقيتني فضربتني وحبستني ولقيتك فصدت وسلمت
فاينا على صاحبه فضحك وخلى سبيله
الحقيقه لست متاكدا من ان رجلا بامكانه ان
يرفض صله ملكا من ملوك الفرس ويصفه بالشؤم
ولكن هذه القصه تروى في مقام يسخر
بالمتطيرين والمتشائمين
[موسيقى]
يقول المثل في بيته يؤتى الحكم فما قصه
هذا المثل
زعمت العرب ان الارنب التقطت تمره
فاختلسها الثعلب فاكلها
فانطلقا يختصمان الى الضب فقالت الارنب يا
ابا الحسل الحسل طبعا ولد الضب اول ما
يخرج من بيضته قال الضب سميعا دعوتي قالت
اتينا لنختصم اليك قال عادلا حكمتما قالت
فاخرج الينا قال في بيته يؤتى الحكم قالت
اني وجدت تمره قال حلوه فكليها قالت
فاختلسها الثعلب قال لنفسه بغى الخير قالت
لطمته قال بحقك اخذتي قالت لطمني قال حرا
انتصر قالت فاقض بيننا فقال حدث حديثين
امراه فان ابت فاربعه اي كرر الكلام مرتين
فان لم تفهم فاربع مرات
ومعنى كلامه انه قد قضى بينهما من قبل ان
تقول له فاقضي بيننا فلذلك قال حدث حديثين
امراه فان ابت فا اربعه اي انها اذا لم
تفهم الحديث من اول مره فلا مانع من ان
تعيده عليها مرات كثيره
يقول ابو الطيب المتنبي فالموت ات والنفوس
نفائس والمستقر بما لديه الاحمق والمرء
يامل والحياه شهيه والشيب اوقر والشبيبه
انزقوا ولقد بكيت على الشباب ولمتي مسوده
ولماء وجهي رونق حذرن عليه قبل يوم فراقه
حتى لكت بماء جفني اشرق
تخيل ان المتنبي الذي يقول هذه الابيات هو
نفسه القائل خلقت الوفا لو رجعت الى الصبا
لفارقت شيبي موجع القلب باكيا اما انا فقد
بكيت على الشباب قبل فراقه حينما كانت
لمتي مسوده ايضا وقلت حينها تسائلني عن
الذكرى عيون وعن نفسي يسائلني حنيني وعن
فرح تعانقه الاماني وعما كان قبلي تساليني
فقبلي كان غير فتى ولكن انا خصباه في قلب
حزين
[موسيقى]
لا تقل استهتر فلان بكذا قل استهتر بكذا
بضم التاء الاولى وكسر الثانيه على ما لم
يسمى فاعله
لا تقل ارض نديه بياء مشدده قل ارض نديه
خفيفه الياء هذا من باب ما يخفف وتشدده
العامه لا تقل نشقت ريحا طيبه قل نشقت
ريحا طيبه بكسر الشين
[موسيقى]
دس الشيء في بعض العميات بمعنى خبا الشيء
واخفاه واندس بمعنى اختبا عن الانظار وهما
كلمتان فصيحه
الربع تستخدم في بعض العميات بمعنى الصحبه
من اهل البيت او الاصدقاء وهو استخدام
فصيح وقديما قال العرب اكثر الله ربعك
الدكه تستخدم في بعض العميات للدلاله على
مكان مرتفع عن الارض يجلس عليه وهو ايضا
استخدام فصيح
[موسيقى]
في يوم من الايام قرر الخليفه ابو جعفر
المنصور ان يزور المدينه المنوره فقال
اتوني برجل له علم بالمدينه ومداخلها
ومخارجها وبيوتها من اجل ان يدلني على
بيوت بني هاشم وسائر بيوتات اهل المدينه
وان يكون
ذا لغه وعلم وادب والمام بالشعر والادب
فجيء بذلك الرجل
فكان يمشي مع المنصور
وكان كلما ساله المنصور سؤالا اجابه باحسن
جواب حتى ان المنصور امر له بجائزه وكان
من حسن ادب هذا الرجل انه لا يبتدئ
المنصور بالحديث الا اذا ساله المنصور
سؤالا فيجيب يعني على قدر السؤال فلما امر
له المنصور بالجائزه تاخر الحاجب في انفاذ
هذا الامر
ومر يوم ومره يومان ومره ثلاثه ايام
والجائزه لم تاتي
حتى كان من امرهما انهما مراه بدار عاتكه
التي يقول فيها الاحوص ما يقول
فابتدر الاعرابي الخليفه سائلا يا امير
المؤمنين اليست هذه دار عاتك التي يقول
فيها الاحوص يا دار عاتكه التي اتعزل حذر
العدى وبك الفؤاد موكل
فاستنكر ابو جعفر المنصور هذا الخروج على
القاعده هذا الرجل قد عوده ان لا يبتدئه
بالكلام الا اذا سال فهذه المره خرج على
هذه القاعده استغرب واستنكر وقال انا لله
وانا اليه راجعون ثم نظر اليه وقال بلى هي
دار رعاتك وظل المنصور يفكر في هذا الامر
ما الذي دعا الرجل الى ان يغير عادته فكان
من ثقافته وذكائه رحمه الله انه استعرض
ابيات القصيده فوصل الى بيت يقول
واراك تفعل ما تقول وبعضهم مذق اللسان
يقول ما لا يفعل فتذكر انه امر له بجائزه
فنادى حاجبه وقال هل انفذتم الجائزه الى
الرجل قال له قال اذا انفذوها وعجلوا بها
اليه وضاعفوها له
فحصل الرجل بهذه
الطريقه وبهذا الذكاء حصل على جائزته
مضاعفه
يا دار عاتكه التي اتعزل حذر العدى وبك
الفؤاد موكل اصبحت امنحك الصدود وانني
قسما اليك مع الصدود الامير تخيل لو كان
ابو جعفر ليس له علم بالشهر والثقافه ومرت
عليه الحادثه هكذا
ايما مرور كان الرجل راحت عليها الجائزه
وراحت عليه
الجائزه الثانيه
هذا طبعا يعني من حسن
ما يتزين به من اجمل ما يتزين به الملوك
والحكام
والامراء الثقافه وسرعه البديهه والنظره
الثاقبه في مجريات الامور
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر ما اوجز وحكمه
خلدها الزمن فيما يلي استعرض معكم بعض ما
وصلني من مشاركاتكم روان تقول قول الحسن
البصري رحمه الله يا ابن ادم انما انت
ايام فاذا ذهب يومك ذهب بعضك
يعني يعني موجزه لكن ليست موجزه كثيرا لكن
شكرا يا روان محمد ابو علي يقول الايام
دول نعم هذه حكمه موجزه
وفيصل ابو الطفيله يقول عين عرفت فذرفت
جميل في ناس تقول المكثار كحاطب ليل
ايضا حكمه موجزه القناعه كنزا لا يفنى
مشاركه من حارث
وامنه تقول ترفق توفق تقول هذا توقيع لكنه
يصلح حكمه فعلا يا امنه صحيح وهو ايضا
موجزا جدا يقول او تقول فاطمه من نظر في
العواقب سلم
نسال الله السلامه زول يابس يقول هذا
الوقت سوف يمضي
هذه من الاشياء التي يتسلى بها المراه عن
كل شيء عندما تقول له هذا الوقت سوف ينظر
يقول استمع لكثيرين وتكلم مع قليلين يقول
هذه ويليام شكسبير
ومحمود يقول راس الحكمه مخافه الله
يوسف الورد يقول ما اشبه اليوم بالبارحه
وهذه قالها طرفه ابن العبد
وعمر يقول كتب عمر بن عبد العزيز الى
الحسن البصري قائلا اما بعد فاني فاذا
وصلك كتاب هذا فاكتب لي موعظه واوجز فرد
عليه الحسن اما بعد اعصي هواك والسلام
الله بهذه الحكمه الموجزه اصل معكم الى
ختام هذه
المشاركات واذكركم دائما بان تضعوا اسم
تاملات الجزيره عند نهايه كل مشاركه من
اجل سهوله الوصول اليها والاستفاده منها
[موسيقى]
هناك احتمال اخر لتتويج مسعانا بغير
الهزيمه ما دمنا قررنا اننا لن نموت قبل
ان نحاول ان نحيا
هذه الكلمات التي ديلت روايتها التي تحمل
مقاطع من سيرتها الذاتيه اثقل من رضوى
يمكنها ان تصف حياه حافله لكاتبتها رضوى
عاشور هذه امراه لم تعرف الهزيمه ولم تكف
عن المحاوله
بابتسامه وديعه تستقبلك رضوى عاشور تكاد
تشعر بهذه الابتسامه وانت تتصفح ايا من
كتبها
وسرعان ما تنسج حولك خيوطا من الالفه
والدفء الذي لا يغادرك بعد ان تنتهي من
القراءه اذا كنت من المحظوظين الذين
عرفوها عن قرب فستعرف انها تشبه كتاباتها
وربما يساورك العجب كيف يمكن لهذه المراه
ضئيله الحجم واندهشت النظره ان تخوض كل
هذه المعارك استمع لها وهي تصف نفسها
قائله
استاذه في التنكر ام شخصيه مركبه الخلق
تجتمع فيها النقائض والاضداد بعد ايام
تقول اتم السابعه والستين قضيت اربعه عقود
منها ادرس في الجامعه صار بعض ممن درستهم
اساتذه لهم تلاميذ لا يا سيدي القارئ لا
استعرض انجازاتي قبل ان انهي الكتاب بل
احاول الاجابه على السؤال الذي طرحته في
اول الفقره لن تنتبه انني في السابعه
والستين لا لان الشيخوخه لا تبدو بعد على
ملامحي ولا لانك لو طرقت بابي الان ستفتح
لك امراه صغيره الحجم نسبيا ترتدي ملابس
بسيطه شعرها صبياني قصير وان كان ابيضه
يغلب اسوده يكاد يغيبه ليس لهذه الاسباب
فحسب بل لان المراه اعني رضوى ما ان تجد
الشارع خاليا نسبيا حتى تروح تركل اي حجر
صغير تصادفه بقدمها اليمنى المره بعد
المره في محاوله لتوصيلها لابعد نقطه
ممكنه
تفعل كاي صبي بقال في العاشره من عمره
يعوضه ركل الحجر الصغير عن ملل رحلاته
التي لا تنتهي لتسليم الطلبات الى المنازل
وعن رغبته في اللعب غير المتاح لانه يعمل
طول اليوم
تاخذها اللعبه تستهويها فلا تتوقف الا حين
تنتبه ان احد الماره يحدق فيها بانتهاش
بين عام الميلاد في القاهره
عام 46 وعامل وفاه عام 2014 عاشت رضوى
عاشور حياه حافله فبعد دراستها للادب
الانجليزي في جامعه القاهره
وحصولها على الماجستير في الادب المقارن
سافرت الى الولايات المتحده لتنال
الدكتوراه في الادب الافريقي ليكون اول
اعلان عن حيازها لقضايا التحرر الوطني وهو
الطريق الذي سارت فيه عندما نشرت اول
اعمالها النقديه بعنوان الطريق الى الخيمه
الاخرى وهي دراسه نقديه عن اعمال الروائي
الفلسطيني غسان كنفاني معلنه التزامها
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه هذا الالتزام رافقها
حتى النهايه
في اثناء الدراسه في كليه الاداب تعرفت
على الشاعر الفلسطيني مريد البرغوثي لتبدا
قصه حب ونضال ورحله حياه وابداع تقول
ورضوى غريب ان ابقى محتفظه بالنظره نفسها
الى شخص ما
طواله 30 عاما ان يمضي الزمن وتمر الاعوام
وتتبدل المشاهد وتبقى صورته كما قرت في
نفسي في لقاءاتنا الاولى
ورغم الظروف السياسيه والابعاد الذي تعرض
له الشاعر الفلسطيني مريد البرغوثي بعد
زياره الرئيس السادات للقدس هذا الابعاد
استمر 17 عاما بقيت جدوه الحب والكفاح لم
تنطفئ يقول مريض البرغوثي عن حبه لرضوى
انت جميله كطن محرر وانا متعب كوطن محتل
انت حزينه
كمخذول يقاوم وانا مستنهض كحرب وشيكه انت
مشتهات كتوقف الغاره وانا مخلوع القلب
كالباحث بين الانقاض انتج صوره كطيار
يتدرب وانا فخور كجدته انت ملهوفه كوالد
المريض وانا هادئ كممرضه
انت حنونه كالرذاذ وانا احتاجك لانو كلانا
جامحا كالانتقام كلانا وديع كالعفو انت
قويه كاعمده المحكمه وانا دهش كمغبون
وكلما التقينا تحدثنا بلا توقف
كمحاميين عن العالم
بعملها البارز ثلاثيه غرناطه استطاعت رضوى
عاشور ان تحجز مكانها بين كتاب الروايه
التاريخيه فعبر روايه تمتد لثلاثه اجيال
استطاعت ان تبعث الحياه في فتره تاريخيه
اقتصر الكلام فيها على صراع الملوك لكنها
كتبت قصه سقوط الاندلس عبر تاريخ عائله
عاصرت هذا السقوط وعلى لساني بطلتها لتصبح
مريم بطله روايتها ايقونه ولتصبح عبارتها
التي اختتمت بها روايتها لا وحشه عند قبر
مريم مثلا يضرب في النساء اللاتي تركن
اثرا لا يمنحي
من اشهر اعمال رضوى الطنطوريه التي ارخت
من خلالها للتغريبه الفلسطينيه وهناك
روايات فرج واطياف وقطعها من اوروبا
وحجر دافئ واثقل من رضوى مقاطع من سيره
ذاتيه بالاضافه الى الترجمه والاعمال
النقديه
اللافت فيما يخص الانتاج الادبي للدكتوره
رضوى عاشور هو هذه العلاقه التي استطاعت
ان تنسجها مع اجيال جديده بعضهم بدا
القراءه ربما بعد رحيلها لكنها ما زالت
تتصدر بعدد من اعمالها قائمه تفضيلاتهم في
القراءه وقوائم الاكثر مبيعا ولا اعرف ان
كانت روحها الدافئه قد استطاعت التسلل
اليهم عبر صفحات كتبها
لتحتويهم بنظرتها العموميه وتمثل لهم
الكثير من الالهام
تقول رضوى رحمه الله
ما الخطا في ان يتعلق الغريق بلوح خشب او
عود او قشه ما الجرم في ان يصنع لنفسه
قنديلا مزججا وملونا لكي يتحمل عتمه
الوانه
وتقول رضوى الذاكره لا تقتل تؤلم الما لا
يطاق ربما ولكننا اذ نطيقه تتحول من
دوامات تسحبنا الى قاع الغرق الى بحر نسبح
فيه نقطع المسافات نحكمه ونملي ارادتنا
عليه
وتقول رضوى الحزن قوه جاذبه تشد لاسفل
تسحب الراس والكتفين الى تحت كان الجسم في
حزنه يمسي واهنا خفيفا
فتستقوي عليه الجاذبيه وتستشرس
[موسيقى]
جاء في البصائر والذخائر ان اعرابيا سئل
اتحسن ان تدعو فقال اللهم انك اعطيتنا
الاسلام من دون ان نسال فلا تحرمنا الجنه
ونحن نسال
ويقول محدثكم فخر المفاخر انني لك مسلم
ولقد مننت به بغير سؤال
فاجب دعائي اذ سالتك جنه ليست تبلغني لها
اعمالي السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]